you're here on I heart that means you've
made it that's how it works how do you
feel you're hanging out with a lot of
people
has anybody setting you up with someone
in bachelor world what's going on no one
has set me up yet but this has been fun
does that mean you're single right I'm
very single
yeah your pal Colton is on bachelor
lockdown now if filming starts this
weekend how do you feel about it all
obviously all the feedback it's
endearing it's flattering that people
have supported me in the way they have
but into its Blake because Colton it was
myself I think all of us would bring
different elements we all would have
done a good job with it and Colton will
do a great job and he'll find his
someone and when I told Colton before
when I was like listen if there's some
of them you don't like but you know
would be a good fit for me have my back
you know take some notes how's he gonna
do be in that virgin bachelor how's he
gonna approach fantasy suites my
prediction is he certainly won't lose
his virginity in the fantasy suite
I think he'll hold it for whoever he
chooses that's what you do other shows
bachelor in paradise winter game so I
wouldn't have done paradise this past
summer I just wasn't ready now I'm ready
so if that opportunity came and I was
single at a time absolutely was it hard
to not ultimately get it or what went
through your mind yeah you know I think
I I think I would have done a good job
and I think it would have been fun I
think I would have I fell in love in a
place I didn't think I would find it did
I found it and because of that I thought
I could transition to that role and find
love and people would want to see the
journey of being heartbroken to find in
your person I think in that forum I
would have done it I would have done a
good job better when did you get the
news because we heard once from Luke
Pell that he found out like as he was
boarding a plane so how did that message
get delivered
Loren's good she's good
we were all informed and there was a
short period of time
burrows announced and we were informed
within a short period time short how
short do you think a couple hours it was
short less than 24 hours
sure okay that's how are you you're good
I'm great I'm great I'm happy for Colton
we're having a good time today and we'll
have a good time in Vegas tonight and
Blake and I are wingman each other all
right we're single ready to mingle ready
to find our person
[Music]